[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
the honest trailer commentary for
mortal kombat again 2021
i'm here with lon i'm here with danielle
we're gonna talk about all of our deep
thoughts about mortal kombat the movie
uh we're gonna show you some deleted
scenes we're gonna answer comments and
questions for viewers like you and we'll
tease you
with next week's honest trailer i'm told
by kevin that this is the most deleted
scenes we've ever had
wow yeah this is we got four full
girthy minutes well i think i think i
understand why
uh and you know people will we'll see as
we go through it because we have too
much to say about mortal kombat
obviously it's just yeah it's just the
the amount of commentary there is to
fight about this movie that's
going in so many predictions but it's
also this was a rare case where we had a
basically a full honest trailer script
done
and then there was a new direction
and it kind of changed a lot mid-stream
and that doesn't always happen
oh man i don't even i don't even know
what happened man i don't know
you weren't around last week for i'll
give a little behind the scenes you
weren't around for a few days last week
so there was a version of it that
danielle and i
and you had worked on that by friday was
sort of done
and then when you came back yesterday uh
you know like it kind of it's not a it's
not a complaint it's just like that's
what happened and so
a lot of the material we'd already
written is probably deleted
true i will say that when i came back
and saw the first cut it was eight and a
half minutes long and that's about five
minutes too long for mortal kombat
[Laughter]
oh god cabal hey i'm cabal i'm
are in a different movie than everyone
else and i want to watch
their movie yeah i would say like i do
take those two guys out
uh just road trip just give them an
excuse
cabal accidentally sent his girlfriend
like a sex tape of him and somebody else
and they got to drive across the country
and go get it they got to drive across
outworld um they could deny the road
trip across a dune buggy yeah
uh well let's start with you danielle
you're the biggest mk head
among us um how did you feel about this
movie
i i i'm in the i'm in the minority and
i'm like
over a lot of the mk heads i liked it i
just i didn't go in with a lot of
expectation and i think for me
that is the spice of life for watching
movies just don't go in
expecting to get everything or anything
that you want
um as you'll see as we talk uh more
about the movie
but yeah i i loved kano kano made me
laugh it was really funny i really liked
the fatalities i liked the way that they
looked for some reason um i think this
is hitting me right on
the the edge of my is it good and i
really like it or is it bad and i really
like it and i think it's hitting me like
right on that kind of
kind of center edge right there right on
the corner of the way that i enjoy my
movies
things can be just okay and i would say
that this is a
just okay film i i i think that there is
a huge
glaring um whole uh a hero shaped hole
at the center of this movie in the form
of cole young
that could they could have totally
focused this on take your pick johnny
cage or make it about the sub-zero and
scorpion or
liu kang or whatever there is no need to
introduce us to a boring
central protagonist like that did you
guys think starting about a third of the
way
as soon as they introduced the idea that
scorpion
and cole young were related like he's
his descendant
i was like oh he's going to become
scorpion like that ancestor is going to
inhabit him and his akana or whatever
will be
just becoming a scorpion that would make
like i legit thought that's where they
were going and i was like okay i get
where this is going
and then they didn't do it and i don't
get why they didn't do it like that's
better than what they did and they must
have thought of it
i truly just assumed cause you know i
played like the first three mortal
kombats and then i picked it back up
with 10 and 11.
i was like okay he must just be from
mortal kombat
7. he must just be a character i missed
that fans love
and they'll be freaking out that they
brought back cole young i just assumed
that there was a point to him you're
like
wonder what the special move is with his
golden shirts
yeah i was like oh it's golden shirt guy
um i must have missed that that dlc
uh lon how do you feel overall about
this one uh i think
like joe starr said at one point uh this
is like they made
the first mortal kombat and mortal
kombat uh annihilation
and then just made it one movie like it
does kind of feel like that
where there's like there's the half of
this movie that's like the ninja stories
and like it's it's trying to kind of
take it pretty seriously and lay the
groundwork for a
mortal kombat franchise with lore and
mythology and all that
and then there's kano and cabal and this
very
like winking self-aware comedy stuff and
it just feels like really pulled in
different directions
and i feel like if they had just picked
one mode or the other i probably would
have liked it
more like i didn't hate it and there was
stuff that i thought worked from both
versions but it just doesn't feel like
one
it feels like a real movie that's being
interrupted by the parody of the movie
well exactly there's the tonal stuff
that doesn't jibe and then there's the
uh the plot decision where it's like you
have a
ready-made structure on which to build a
mortal kombat movie which is
it's a fighting tournament there are so
many
movies built around a tournament and you
know the beats already and so you don't
have to worry about that part you know
he's the newcomer into the tournament
he's going to make friends with one guy
the main bad guy is going to kill him
and he's going to get real mad and
defeat him at the i'm just describing
bloodsport
which ironically world combat 1 was sort
of based on didn't they have a whole
rights thing with jean-claude that we
allude to anyways the
there are a million of those movies that
work um so the idea to make this about
the prep for the tournament which is
gonna be part of like a three or four
movie long
mortal combat arc is like don't assume
you're gonna get more mortal combat
movies just do a mortal combat movie and
throw your best stuff at the wall
um so yeah i mean i don't like that in
general to like
pay to see the movie and then or stream
it on hbo max i guess
and then like but it's really just set
up for the next movie like
even if it's setting up another movie i
get it that's how it works now
everything's got to be a franchise
that's fine but you still got to give me
like a movie's worth of movie you know
like
they're trying to kind of give you the
first third of the movie
as a full first movie and it's like no
no no you can't
we got to see some of the tournament you
can't end before the tournament even
starts
and what really bugged me is at the very
end both shang tsung
and raiden get speeches about how
basically
the work's just beginning like they both
get setting up
number two where it's like well none of
this mattered i'll get you next time i
was like come on
like don't do that like at least let me
feel like i saw something
yeah i i and i'm not mad like oh they
didn't
i i need to see a tournament an
officially sanctioned tournament like
i just think that that's like because
all the terminators is
excuses for people to have one-on-one
martial arts fights and there were
plenty of those
um i'm just saying that it's like it's
easier to build a movie around that and
i feel like they over complicated
or they made their work harder in trying
to build this world with
akanas and like trying to explain all
the backstory where this comes from like
i don't really need to know and the
stuff that they added isn't very good
anyways i can accept that we live in a
world where people can shoot fireballs i
don't need to know why
just have them shoot the fireball
anyways we'll talk more about that let's
get into the uh because we got a lot of
deletes to get through
uh let's watch mortal kombat 2021
[Music]
after one fun movie and a sequel that
felt like sniffing glue in the dumpster
behind the arcade
too bad you will die
comes a reboot that will try to please
the biggest fans of the legendary
fighting game
splat seems that throughout history
different cultures all over the world
they
reference a great tournament look my
research shows that there's
realms and species that we didn't even
know existed
who are you people moral comment for the
story is like watching pornhub for the
comment section
do you want a martial arts flick that
takes itself way too seriously
or do you want a campy b movie full of
wings to the audience
get over here yes in a film with
dramatic scenes where lou kang can't
stop his cousin from getting sucked down
also that's funny um but the it is
true to the games and as far as i've you
know seriously played like four of them
that it is that mix of like complete
campy grindhouse gore stuff and like
just
admittedly stupid characters that are
just pallet swap versions of each other
and like an incredibly serious like
warhammer 40k
style like lore upon lore upon lower
dump like that those are that's the
games i feel like they kind of captured
it
yeah and maybe that's why i liked it
more than i think more people did even
though i'm not even up on all the lore
of the stuff like sometimes i go back
and i'm like wait that happened because
you have to you know go and
separate the endings from what actually
is considered to be canon um but i do
think that that might be a reason why i
liked it more than more
more people did because i'm like yeah no
this is the game this is what it is
uh dumb lore and then heads coming off
i i just think it's it's the tone it's
not it's not that you can't mix like a
lot of elaborate lore and then like kano
b and kano
i just think it's like it's got to feel
like you know in a movie
in a video game i guess it doesn't even
matter as much like i played a bunch of
mortal kombat games and didn't know
and all the story i know is just from
movies for me it's like
the story is you you know back for two
seconds and then forward b
but uh like uh uh yeah i
i just think it's it's it's just it's a
weird mishmash like sometimes
sometimes i didn't even know if i was
supposed to be taking it seriously in
that moment or if i was
it was just all tongue-in-cheek goofing
around can i say has anyone ever
conducted a real-life investigation
where you cover all the walls in a room
with
like scraps of sort of vaguely related
paper like
i don't even get how that's supposed to
be helpful in this case she just like
pasted everything she knows about mortal
kombat it's cinematic line it's
cinematic
imagine if you were just looking at
someone's messy uh computer desktop and
you just had a bunch of files
wait wait where did i leave that even in
homeland when it was supposed to be kind
of like she was losing it there's like
pieces of string and like lines
connecting things
sonya's is just all over there and she
just she just made a collage
yeah yeah it's more like one of those
secret boards than yeah it's just like
like a teenage girl's bedroom but i
think i saw nicolas he's got a crush for
vacation to maui
very excited yeah i uh maybe that's what
i'll do with the wall behind me i'll
tune in next week just see agoro
collage which is track and goro here's
everything i've learned about goro
all right four arms where liu kang can't
stop his cousin from getting sucked off
he's about to get his soul sucked and
goofy scenes where he spams back plus
low kick until his opponent ragequits
re-enter the world of mortal kombat and
when i say
world of mortal combat i mean the
sandpit where everyone pre-games before
mortal kombat actually starts
because when it comes to the tournament
it will have to wait for the sequel
and even then screw it everything's made
up and the points no matter
and read a cast full of legit martial
artists not that you'd ever know it
cause it's shot with so many quick cuts
it feels like your game is lagging
yeah i feel like this was such a huge
miss opportunity when like it's right
there in front of you you
they clearly hired martial artists in
all of the main martial arts fighting
roles and then to shoot them like it's
liam neeson hopping a fence and taking
three
it just seems criminal with a k i i just
feel like
you can like there's so many i think
admittedly
by the director's own admission he's
like this isn't an action movie this is
a martial arts movie then shoot it like
one
like let him do their thing they train
for this
yeah i was really disappointed because i
feel like that was kind of the selling
point too
is like look unlike the last time we
just cast like pretty hollywood people
who kind of looked like the characters
this time we went and got people who
could really fight and do the
action and i was like and they could and
they're doing it yeah yeah so it's like
even if the story doesn't you know who
cares even if it doesn't look great or
whatever at least we'll get a bunch of
cool fights and then yeah it kind of
hacks them all up there's still some
really cool like moments in the movie i
don't want to totally understand it but
yeah
uh but yeah it's not as cool as it could
be
with these guys we're used to seeing and
stuff like the night comes for us
or the raid or like stuff where you know
you really get to see the fights play
out
agreed um anywho let's keep going
and by the ancient rivalry that the
trailer sold you on
scorpion versus sub-zero
kidding they have one fight at the
beginning and a quickie at the end
instead follow along with cole young
the harry potter of luke skywalker's i'm
an orphan
it's not a birthmark call you won't find
this character in your prima guide
but you will find him getting his ass
kicked by everyone
he's a washed-up mma jobber who takes
fight advice from a little girl
but when cole lives up to the legacy of
being scorpion's trust fund kid
you're a descendant of one of the
greatest ninjas
to ever walk the earth he'll transform
from cole young punching bag
to cole young a guy with a tight shirt
and some billy clubs uh no intel
scorpion but i think stryker may have
banged his wife
but cole's not alone
that's deep cut right there right uh
anybody else know stryker
mortal kombat three yeah
he's a cop that's his power that's his
power really
i mean it's the full force of the law
behind look it's uh
you know legit that's a real power he's
got 38 arrests and 47 fatalities on his
record
it's still working a lot of brutalities
too
not so many friendships um yeah but
that's the beauty of mortal kombat is
you can have like
a demon fighting a cop and like you
don't need to explain
oh he got his cop arcana powers when he
you know did an especially brutal
takedown and like a taser appeared in
his hand
like it's just random people showing up
each has their own reason for being
there
it's like a tournament like a fighting
tournament yeah it all i mean this is
one of those things that
you know people if you complain about a
movie and people try to
sort of explain it to you with stuff
from the movie like well no you need to
find your akana because a thousand years
ago and it's like
they could have made it anything they
were they could make like when humans go
to out world
they all develop one special power and
you don't know what it's going to be
boom like you can come up with anything
you want because it's
fictional and stupid so to come up with
this it takes a whole movie
of just like sparring to like find
your chi or whatever it's just like why
make us go
around like it just i don't know it
feels a little bit like spinning our
wheels
yeah i mean yeah and cole young i mean
they they set him up as a
mma champion like a title holder in i
don't know if
they can't say ufc but he is a champion
and he is now
getting his ass kicked for 200 bucks
like there are easy players
i feel like there's a there's a plot
thing missing there's like a reference
at one point he makes to like
they were like you're a champion he's
like not these days and it's like we
didn't do we find out what happened
why he sucks now
where it's like something happened it's
like his save the cat thing like he did
a good thing but it ended up causing him
to be injured and he was out for a few
years and now
he's struggling to get back like it
feels like we're missing that connection
yeah no he's just terrible now
like now he just he just seems like he
sucks and that's not a good setup for
your mortal kombat protagonist until you
get him angry
you don't want to get him angry because
if you get him angry he puts on clothes
yeah there you go yeah yeah his
child has to be threatened at all times
or he can't fight
it's like that old do you ever see that
old human giant sketch with the
the mom movers right your child would
have to be in danger for
that's cole young and like that was his
whole motivation is like i want to
protect my family but it
doesn't quite jive with like why do i
keep saying jibe today
stop talking um it doesn't quite mesh
with a guy who's like
can't stop fighting for 200 bucks a pop
like get an office job like you
give it up this is not do you're not
doing this for your family anymore
if you're fighting like unlicensed cage
fights and getting your spleen ruptured
like for
for a couple couple bills also you can't
have
i do everything for family that's
already dom toretto find your own
find your own action movie bit cole
young
yeah it's all about family is taken
all right let's keep going oh is not
alone
test your might and patience against a
massive roster of fighters
like liu kang kung lao and raiden
guardians of a secret cult that helps
branded people fulfill their potential
sonja blade a woman hey no girls allowed
the training areas for the chosen ones
um
whoops jax who goes from having nice
arms to no arms
to bad arms to good arms before you can
ask
wait what would his powers be if he
never lost his arms
oh shang tsung a sorcerer who can't wait
to leave our world because
i mean come on look at it a bunch of
c-listers who are just there to donate
blood
the animation team for mortal kombat
annihilation and of course
kano ah laser beam better than fireballs
i don't know if this is a credit to the
actor or an insult to the script but man
kano is by far the best part of this
thing as you hate to love or australia's
main export
yeah pause i loved kano i mean
a few times he went a little too much
with the shtick or like the pop culture
references and stuff like that but by
and large
that actor like great reaction faces
great reaction lines and i feel like a
lot of it
didn't it didn't feel scripted like he
was just thrown out there like
like when you throw out the sad trombone
after sonja
[Laughter]
couldn't get her a little like akana or
whatever like it was the whole first
hour of the movie seemed like
the kano show and i kind of liked it i
mean i was like this is a weird choice
this is the kano movie
okay but um uh man i hope we see him and
more
stuff and by him i mean kano yeah effin
whoops
is like was such a surprise i i had to
turn the movie off and just laugh for
like a minute straight and keep
rewinding it because it was so funny
yeah i just i feel like that's the
energy i want
all my mortal kombat at i don't want
some of my mortal kombat at a three
and then kano at a nine i want the whole
thing
in at nine the whole time that it's just
when cabal and kana were doing their
stick i was like
yes more yes give me all this and then
you'd go back to like
cole and jack's and it would be like
well now it feels kind of somber again
and like i just don't i don't need all
of the oh i'm doing this for
my family and love and whatever
redemption
arc stuff it's mortal kombat make it
crazy
yeah i mean you can have one you can
have one somber guy just like you can
have one like stoic
monk but they did kung lao liu kang and
raiden are
kind of the same bring the same energy
and then sonia
and jax are bringing the same energy
it's like you have all these characters
give each of them a thing just one thing
and then then
that's how you get a stew going anyways
let's keep watching
so strap in for a feature-length teaser
for a future movie that may one day
contain
a mortal kombat tournament that does a
decent enough job of bringing the world
to the screen
but refuses to move anything forward or
develop any stakes at all
death is only another portal but who
cares
weirdest here to watch fatalities
without learning the button combos
movie wins adequate victory
starring dom seeking sub
frosty the ronin see my vest
see my vest the girl wants the dragon
tattoo
the croc hunter booyah welcome
to the scorch hey at least he's not a
white guy this time
the sunken place brim job you got a
little something on your
no a little bit lower no it's kind of
everywhere
it's literally all over your face for
loco
clever go and any excuse to play cliffs
from kung pao enter the fist
[Music]
what were you saying before the show
long that people that this is a
reference that doesn't
i hold up this was when this was
suggested i thought that this was going
to be another one of those things that
we were doing for
the oldies like us who remember kung pao
enter the fifth
because in my brain there was a whole
generation coming up
that would not remember it's only 19
years old
it is uh steve odekirk's uh you know
salute to martial arts films
um but apparently i'm the [ __ ]
and everybody in the comments is like
hooray we love kung pao under the fifth
so
what do i know yeah it's it's hard to
know that line and that i think that's
why we couched it with any excuse like
well
we're kind of reaching but i think that
there are a lot of parallels
my complaint was not that there are not
a lot of parallels
there definitely are yeah it was just i
didn't realize anybody under 30
remembered i don't know but uh
and i haven't rewatched it probably in
10 years but um
joestar sent us that like hey what about
this and i was like oh
boom yes definitely and i'm glad i'm
glad it turned out well we'll have to do
a group watch of that and
hope it's still funny betty all right
keep going it's not a birthmark cole
means you've been chosen
[Music]
fighting requires both attacking and
defending not just throwing punches you
should try it sometime we have purposely
trained him wrong
as a joke get over here
unreal tournament
where are all my favorite mortal kombat
characters spawn
predator robocop schwarzenegger now
that's a sequel worth baiting for
[Applause]
there you go yeah uh i actually was a uh
uh a kano player so i'm happy that he
got he got the star treatment um he was
my main and then uh i used to play cyrax
he has yet to make an appearance he's
the yellow version of the red
uh robot um that we got of cabal that we
got
in this booth did you guys know that the
guy who
voices there's two actors there's the
one who's in the suit and then there's
the guy doing the voiceover
the voiceover guy played cabal is uh i
think it's damien herod
harrington i forget his his real name
he's the guy who played charlie manson
in both
mind hunter and once upon a time in
hollywood isn't that no
and probably from what it sounds like
one of the good feathers from animaniacs
yes i believe he is he's like he's an
australian actor so he's doing
that's more approximating his real voice
is cabal
wow he was supposed to sound australian
no i'm saying he is the actor himself is
australian okay yeah i guess that makes
it did sound like an australian guy
doing like a hey i'm walking here
exactly yes it's an australian guy doing
a weird
not australian accent makes sense well
um before we get into the uh deleted
scene montage thank you guys so much for
watching please like
please subscribe please hit that bell
and you'll never miss a thing
uh like that aerosmith song um okay
so we have a lot of outtakes uh as as
noted uh we did
uh a big cut down on this one did a lot
of rearranging
uh i haven't seen these in a while let's
see if they make any sense let's roll
the glee it scenes
hope that you got hyped because the
movie only teases the song into the
credits
and even then it's a remix kids these
days
i mean these are pretty sick but the
best fatalities are the ones that make
you want to laugh and puke at the same
time
[Laughter]
more like this please
maybe they're saving those for mortal
kombat annihilation
[Music]
i mean is it just me or does it kill the
impact when everyone's blood looks like
purple drank
i need realistic blood effects like this
giving us plenty of time to explore new
ideas like passing on this dragon-shaped
murder std
and the mystical concept of arcana
because why watch people with magic
powers fight
when you could watch them explain where
those powers come from and why they
can't have them
your inner power comes from your arcana
without it
defeating up world will be impossible we
have no time to lose
you must unlock your arcana how do i
find my arcana
it must come from your soul whatever it
is that drives you
a fighter without a mocking can never
achieve their arcana and a fighter
without an akana is a liability to the
others
cut this bullcrap
and a fighter without an arcana is a
liability to the others
movie wins borality
led by the mortal kombat franchise
legend cole young wait who
is cole young i don't see him in my
prima guide
oh he's not from the game there's like
900 characters and they had to add
another one
does john claude van damme own the rice
to johnny cage or something stupid
sub-zero an evil elsa with the power to
freeze the very blood in your body
but mostly uses it to make pretty ice
sculptures liu kang
kung lao and raiden boring guardians of
a literal hole in the ground
sonia blade who puts the k in conspiracy
theorist
wait what would his powers be if he
never lost his arms laser mustache
he'll transform from cole young punching
bag to
cole young shirt owner man i can't wait
to never
plays this guy in the games ever
starring spawn the tethered
ninja garden shogun world
joe chill cool in the shang hashtag
justice for bihan
jack frost whiner uppercut the golden
manchild
splatterstar pummeling young woman
cammy blade of glory australian for
beardo
gazer beam private boomerang arcana
battle angel
flame jumper zuko the lightning chief
storm meet brawley sparks
broden i'm a god i'm not d guys
wow lon you were worried about
kung pao into the fist reference and you
put a meet wally sparks joke in there i
feel like with starring
that's our chance to shoot the moon
that's where i put in my old man
references
uh meep brawley sparks come on that's
good
i get it does not write that down
meanwhile sparks is a terrible late nazi
danger field movie
yeah yeah all right anyways keep going i
believe it was
second to last before my five wives was
that his last one
fist vow to train your dragon pharrell
jamiroquoi bloody face empty pockets
psy side chick merc without a mouth
uric high af picture me trollin
or cop limitless me after i get my
second dose
godzilla versus bong iguana man
fallout new vegas mask of the sarcasm
interdimensional cabal and gnarly quinn
and captain hammer
get out world bland sport
nice to see you mortal kombat
mulligan
one of the iron laws of martial arts
movies if you come across a guy who's
meditating
he's about to [ __ ] you up
flawless victory
kano lou kang raiden
johnny cage scorpion cole young
yeah this is not gonna work
yeah um a lot of times like this is one
where we wanted to make
jokes about the music but my god weirdly
we are uh
seemingly allowed to play any clip from
any movie uh but if we so much as hum
the tune of a copywritten song like
a million macedonian uh bots like
flag the video so we just kind of have
avoided doing anything
uh any joke about any music at all that
would require us to play it but it's
tough sometimes it's really tough
because the music in a movie is funny
and we want to make fun of it but
yeah they're really good at spotting
that uh go figure
um anyways that was fun um yeah
yeah trailers right guys
this doesn't like those i like these i
like it when we do a movie like this
it was bad but good um keeps it
interesting
so um let's see
evan jay pretzel you're flooding the
zone evan stop submitting so many
questions we're only going to answer one
um all right mj pretzel asked what video
game would make for a genuinely good
movie or tv show which has not already
been discussed by the public
i would watch an old republic of star
wars or star wars older public uh
adaptation uh i feel like there is a
movie that's maybe
it's one of those ones that comes up a
lot as maybe is gonna get an adaptation
but
horizon zero dawn is a really cool
setup for a game that's in a really cool
world that i feel like i would like to
see
realize on screen i also think and i
know that that's been talked about but
bioshock guillermo del toro was going to
do it for a while that's another like
that'd be great
very cool setting for a move
um i've been playing a lot of stardew
valley uh
yeah it's a cute little game and i think
if you do something like that where it's
just like a villager comes to town
because he's tired of his old day job
and
he comes to town and starts dating all
the women and the men and they start
getting into fights
uh that's just real housewives on a farm
baby
yeah it's gotta say it depends how you
play it because it could be minari
or it could be like temptation island um
like every fourth netflix original where
it's got a name like
virgin falls
and it's just like she gets divorced and
moves to a small town in vermont full of
hunky people hunky farm hands
yeah um i'm a big fan of the
uh of the x-com games i think that they
uh they give like a skeleton of a plot
that kind of leaves room to adapt where
it's like it's an alien invasion movie
but like we get our asses kicked like
humanity's really losing for a long time
until we like sort of become more like
the aliens and then turn the tide i
think is like an interesting
kind of meta-narrative of those games is
like you we kind of lose our humanity to
fight back against uh against an alien
invasion which i don't know i don't know
if i've seen a show like that or because
it's kind of a dark
it's a it's a it's a bittersweet victory
in the end when like we have like these
giant
enlarged frontal lobes because like now
humans are psychic and we're like
covered in laser beams and stuff like
that it's like
we win question mark i think that
i think that'd be a cool uh cool setup
for something all right
um adam halbert asks love that you had
epic voice guys shout mortal kombat
again what's your favorite line for him
to say i don't know he always surprises
me like
i'll have just a favorite like just
something that'll make me laugh just
because of the way jon says it
every trailer and you know uh for the
first
year or so his catchphrase was just
saying boobs
um and i think that is worn out it's
welcome but i do think that
sometimes you can find other eu noises
that still make me laugh
but when he doesn't do a different work
um but yeah i don't know
do you guys have any any john isms that
that make you chuckle
i mean this surprises no one but this is
it it's always going to be mortal kombat
and especially when we get him to
actually
list out the names oh oh beautiful great
job john
i uh any any time he's he's doing
uh you know an impression like his his
impressions are very good
and i like that he doesn't always have
to do like you can even hear it in
mortal kombat
when he does see my vest and he's given
it he's given it like
20 or bach but he's not it's not a full
lumiere
impression he's just suggesting it and
it's that kind of subtle work that i
think
really makes john's voice over shine
yeah i like this question from adam
shuring uh
who's your nightmare pick to play johnny
cage in the sequel
it definitely teased like it ends on a
shot of a johnny cage post yeah oh yeah
they're definitely letting us know it's
the
worst possible johnny cage
oh jeez uh
i'm gonna go ahead and say james corden
i don't want to see james corbett isn't
he like an annoying [ __ ] so it's like
okay yeah
i buy it yeah just don't that's not it's
not something i would like to see
you know who i think should do it while
you guys are thinking yeah
zac efron oh he'd be great wouldn't he
be a great like i feel like he could
both play it comedically over the top it
would be
sort of ironically funny just to see him
in that role but also like
believable enough as a dude who could
punch you and it would hurt
yeah yes sticking with cats i'm gonna go
with jason derulio i think would be
like not a great choice i think he'd
keep saying his own name over and over
again instead of saying johnny cage
and that would appear still as
rum tugger though i'm assuming oh
definitely is rum
tugger just occasionally yelling out for
milk yeah right yes
the first name that popped into my head
was dane cook but i actually feel like
he has
good johnny cage energy yeah he might
nail it
yeah yeah yeah i don't know i guess it's
a it's pretty flexible because you can
be
an obnoxious over exposed actor and like
that's that's the character
so it kind of can work on a metal level
let's just say josh gad and move on
oh yeah fair yeah all right next
question
um uh do you think they took it from
jeffrey elverton do you think they took
it for granted that they'd get a sequel
by not doing the actual tournament yes
they did take for granted but yes they
are getting sequels uh allegedly and i
think this was a big hit so
yeah you're gonna get more um
let's see a question about the golden
globes that's very interesting but
that's not what this video is about
langley uh we'll answer that on sju
tomorrow
uh let's see in the wake of this evan j
uh
oh god damn it evan jay pretzel [ __ ]
gun
i'm skipping cut off buddy
uh whoever's served whoever's adding the
uh
the the questions and comments in here
can we keep the keep them sort of uh
uh on mortal kombat this this isn't sju
someone's asking about rita ora and
taekwon td cuddling
um ben's eye tempted say you should have
titled this stream on his trailer's
commentary with the k missed opportunity
uh ryan please change that now
thank you um and jeffrey elberton writes
should reptile have been a human
lizard-like hybrid like he was in the
first game
which would be different from the
original movies yeah i think they really
blew it
it's an unforced error with reptile like
you don't need to make him
why do they keep making him into a
lizard like i know he can do that but
he's just a
green sub-zero or scorpion like that's
fine and then he takes up the mask and
has a lizard tongue
done yeah i i was i especially because
shanks
gets a whole line like called the lizard
reptile
he gives him like whatever his name is i
don't remember what it is
uh sizzleroth or something and uh so you
think you're gonna get a guy like you
that that that really because
this thing seems like they keep it in a
cage not that you'd like
give them a ring and be like hey shang
tsung wants you so it's a real
misdirect it it feels like a really
missed opportunity and
it just kind of looks like a like a
komodo dragon who's standing on his back
legs it's not a very
inspired design yeah as much as i want
to watch a dude punch a lizard i don't
want to watch anyone punch that lizard i
guess which is supposed to be the whole
point
yep it looked like that you remember the
viral video
from last month of the lizard and like
the thai bodega where it just like
climbed up onto the groceries and like
sat
on the shelf it looked like that it
didn't look like uh
like i'm gonna punch this lizard it
looked like oh this lizard has found its
way inside
let us help it right now
all right final question uh from frank
clark uh if you had to go out
in a fatality which would you choose
what's the fatality that's uh
that's putting you in the dirt any any
uh any initial thoughts
his mind is johnny cage uh when he um
he like rips your head off and then uses
it as like a ventriloquist dummy to like
make a little goof
i think that'd be that'd be nice it's
quick and painless and you leave him
with a laugh
yeah i think most fatalities aren't
really that bad because you you're dying
quickly like they're like humiliating
but what do you care
you're you're dead i mean like you have
like 15 seconds of extreme pain max
yeah and then it's like so i yeah i'm
sort of agnostic because like i feel
like uh
you know uh being being like drawn along
the ground
going into a hat that's functioning as a
buzzsaw that one i'd want to avoid
because there's a few moments where
you're like
i know what's about to happen to you but
like being
being punched in my skeleton just flies
out the top of my head like i know
i'm not aware of that happening go for
it yeah i like the one where jax gets
really big and then just stomps you like
a bug yes
yes that's a good one for some reason um
yeah or i think
smoke blows up the earth and
um if i can't enjoy earth neither can
anyone else
i think it's a planet-wide facade i'm
pretty sure there's one where he
detonates the entire is there a genocide
bonus in mortal kombat
no in fact the next fight goes on as
planned which raises a lot of questions
not even a planet to fight for it yeah
uh but i'll pick a friendship if i could
i'll take one of those um all right well
thank you guys so much for watching i
i think this is just uh this was just a
delight to talk to you guys and to do
this movie for honest trailers but
next week will be maybe even more fun
and who knows maybe
if it's not too much of an inconvenience
maybe we'll have uh maybe we'll have
some special guests uh next week we'll
see
um because we're doing a very special
movie um something that is
uh let's say a calculated risk
that's uh that's your clue uh i can't
wait for that too
uh thank you lon thank you danielle
we'll see you next week for honest
trailer commentaries tomorrow's sgu
see you later bye
[Music]
you